alors si on s'intéresse à ce business
encore une fois j'ai été toujours
d'ailleurs on en a déjà parlé ici des
placements de produits on a déjà parlé
de ça je suis désolé on a pas personne
n'attend du goût bas pour en parler on
en a déjà parlé ici et à chaque fois
j'ai été là pour en parler avec
transparence voilà et je leur ferai tout
le temps et s'il faut durcir on durcira
mais je ne peux pas tolérer un
harcèlement en meute d'accord ce sens
par leur espace voilà c'est pas possible
oui mais la sphère a commencé comme ça
c'est que j'ai juste veux juste que
chronologiquement on remette les choses
à leur place et c'est pour ça que je
suis venu parce que je veux que les gens
qui vous regardent l'entendre parce que
lundi n'ont pas attendre ils n'ont pas
entendu dans ses poumons harcèlement une
enquête a été ouverte pour moi
harcèlement les mains sur la tête de
booba sont venus ce que mme lagarde a
dit c'est que le placement police sur un
prétexte pour cyber harcelé c'est ce que
vous dites donc pour booba oui qu'est ce
qui s'est passé au départ
je ne sais pas je ne connais pas booba
en fait je ne le sais pas je ne connais
pas cette personne je n'ai jamais
travaillé que lui je ne lui ai jamais
parlé parce que booba ce qui dit je te
le dis mamie comme ça au moins
c'est exactement et moi je lui parlerai
également il dit qu'en fait lui sa
guerre c'est contre vous parce que
niveau l'allèle tous ces gens là sont
des fonds des concerts de la société et
qu'ils arnaque les gens qu'ils arnaque
son public qu'ils arnaque mon public qui
sernhac ttt clients et que voilà c'est
ce qu'il dit et c'est si bon exemple
quand on me dit que c'est son combat
voilà est ce que toi aujourd'hui
tu as le sentiment que il a des preuves
sur sa comme quoi c'est pas que tu vois
pas ce qu'il y'a pas que toi y'a pas que
magali babin comme société
d'influenceurs en a plein d'autres et
apparemment de ce qu'on me dit en plus
ce serait là la plus propre shauna evans
voilà près de chez moi j'en suis très
loin c'est vraiment c'était très près
mais qu'est ce qui sert à quoi
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui fait qui dit
qu' il ya des gens qui se font arnaquer
il ya des gens qui aient à y aller a dit
il ya des gens qui nous regardent qui
achètent des produits quatre fois plus
cher alors que voilà ça coûte 10 balles
et il est et ça n'aurait peut-être
handball hockey est ce que c'est ça ça
c'est ce que c'est la vérité ou pas mais
je viens de l'expliquer évidemment qu'il
ya eu des dérives ces termes nous vos
métiers pas très longtemps c'est allé
très vite aujourd'hui ça n'est plus un
nouveau métier on n'a plus droit aux
erreurs qu'on avait le droit au début
forcément on était pas voilà ça sans
cadre au fur et à mesure et encore une
fois il faut mettre des règles en place
si je dis ça c'est que bien évidemment
qu'il ya eu il ya eu des signes mais
c'est pas maintenant en fait est là lui
envie de vous dire c'est un peu tard
parce que des lanceurs d'alerté y en a
avant il y en a eu depuis déjà miné ils
sont sur les réseaux sociaux et encore
une fois ils le font proprement parce
qu'à partir du moment où on se rend
compte qu'il ya une 40 problème les
choses en place après on va parler
partiellement mais au niveau parce que
je vais lancer un appel d'ailleurs à
tous les gens voient là parce que c'est
vrai que c'est cesser c'est inadmissible
il ya des gens qui disent que la femme
de david douillet aussi a fait une vidéo
comme quoi elle s'était fait arnaquer
les femmes david douillet elle est là
elle a pris en placement chez nous
l'influent seul n'a pas placé ces jeunes
étaient même pas là je vais vous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé je sortais
excusez moi je je me retire de ma
belle-soeur donc j'ai pas suivi son truc
quand tu arrivé dans l'entreprise elle a
fait des vidéos partout sur les réseaux
sociaux pour dire j'ai pas eu mon
placement etc elle a été remboursée elle
voulait absolument parler j'étais pas en
jeu je suis désolé gtc vous savez ce qui
me l'année dernière voilà et les donc
écoutez le l'assistant du directeur
enfin le responsable commercial lala
appelé le poste n'a pas été fait ou je
crois qu'il a été fait on lui en a
offert un jeu c'est plus et c'est en
fait on peut pas à chaque à chaque fois
qu'on n'est pas contents d'un truc à les
appeler voilà y ait sur les réseaux
sociaux multiples ce que vous êtes en
train de saab et on a à peu près
peut-être 3500 clients par an je vous
laisse un calcul depuis 2016 si j'en ai
une ou deux qui se plaignent sur les
réseaux sociaux qui sont pas content
j'ai envie de dire je suis désolé on
n'est pas parfait aucune entreprise
française n'est parfaite et que des fois
je ne sais même pas si elle a tort à la
raison que c'est peut-être nous qui
avons tort je suis pas là pour parler de
ça en fait mais mais sait on est une
entreprise comme une autre il ya des
choses des fois qu'ils se font bien tout
ce que je sais c'est que aujourd'hui
nous nos influences heures sont en
conformité nous on leur demande de
mettre les hashtag sponsorisé de
prévenir le consommateur depuis 2017 et
ça c'est pas moi qui le dit je sais
c'est tout le monde nous on demande à
nos influences heures de prévenir le
consommateur qui sont payés pour cette
promotion depuis 2010 est d'accord on a
été un des seuls sur le marché un des
seuls parce qu'elle a certains qui le
font je suis pas là pour dire c'est moi
la meilleure pas du tout il y en a qui
le font il y en a qui le font pas voilà
donc mais en tout cas nous on monde donc
c'est tout il ya des choses qui sont
bien pas bien comme partout